RIGHT THERE.
>> Tucker: LIFE AROUND YOU DID
GRADE YEAR BY YEAR END YOU THINK
I'M I GUESS THAT'S JUST THE WAY
IT IS NOW.
AND OCCASIONALLY SOMEONE STEPS
FORWARD AND SAYS NO, IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE THAT WAY.
YOU COULD ACTUALLY FIX THIS.
IT'S NOT THAT COMPLICATED.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MESSAGES THAT
SHERIFF ALEC VILLANUEVA HAS BEEN
TELLING THE REST OF US HERE IN
LOS ANGELES.
HE JOINS US, WE ARE HAPPY THAT
HE IS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING IS
COMPLICATED, BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S COMPLICATED TO SAY THE
ACTIONS OF ONE PROSECUTOR REALLY
HAVE CHANGED HERE.
>> DEFINITELY.
AND ITS FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE,
THE FIRST FULL YEAR, HE REJECTED
OVER 12,200 CASES FOR MY AGENCY
ALONE.
AND MULTIPLY THAT BY TWO, THAT
IS ALL THE OTHER LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS IN THE L.A.P.D.
SO HIS EFFORTS ARE REALLY
NULLIFYING THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT IN SACRAMENTO WHERE
MISDEMEANOR CRIMES ARE SELDOM
PROSECUTED.
IF HE BELIEVES IT'S ATTACHED TO
HOMELESSNESS OR DRUG ABUSE, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO TOUCH HIM.
SO OBVIOUSLY THAT'S FOSTERING A
CLIMATE WHERE HOMELESSNESS, DRUG
ABUSE IS JUST SPIRALING OUT OF
CONTROL.
YOU ARE SEEING IT WITH YOUR OWN
EYES.
>> Tucker: YOU CERTAINLY ARE.
ANYONE WHO SPENT A LOT OF TIME
IN L.A., THERE'S -- IT REALLY IS
A GOOD CITY.
IT'S GOTTEN WIDESPREAD THERE'S
NO ARGUING THAT.
HE'S THE PROSECUTOR, YOU ARE THE
SHERIFF, THERE SHOULD BE A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO OF
YOU.
HAVE YOU BROUGHT THIS TO HIS
ATTENTION?
>> I'VE HAD ONE CONVERSATION
WITH THEM AND THAT WAS HIS FIRST
WEEK IN OFFICE WHERE WE HAD THE
ISSUE OF MUTUAL CONCERN ON ONE
PARTICULAR CASE, BUT HIS
PREDECESSOR WE MET EVERY THREE
MONTHS.
I MET HER AND HER OFFICE, SHE
MET IN MY OFFICE.
THIS GENTLEMAN, AND LESS YOU
COME FROM THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE, YOU WORRY BLACK LIVES
MATTER ACTAVIS.
EVERYONE ELSE DOES DOESN'T EXIST
IN THIS WORLD.
>> ONE QUESTION SINCE YOU LIVE
HERE AND RUN A BIG AGENCY, IS
THERE HUGE PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR
HIS POLICIES?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
I'M SEEING A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM
VICTIMS.
VICTIMS MATTER.
THAT SHOULD BE AT THE FOREFRONT
OF EVERYTHING, ALL OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
NOW IT IS ALL OFFENDER-CENTRIC.
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT REDUCING
HARM OF INCARCERATION FOR THOSE
WHO COMMIT CRIME.
AND THAT IS AN ASTONISHING LEAP
OF LOGIC THAT NOT JUST GEORGE
GASCON, BUT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, HAS EMBRACED THE
VERY SAME IDEA.
WHICH IS THEN AN ABSOLUTE FIGURE
HERE IN L.A. COUNTY.
>> I HOPE YOU TAKE THIS PLAY
OVERCO